what is up guys it's your boy reaction
channel 69 and right now we're going
we're okay well I guess we're not a
reaction channel well we are an analysis
channel and we at earlier today had a
live stream code geass theories live
stream where a feel you mentioned that a
new sort of preview teaser trailer just
came out for the sequel for the Code
Geass sequel it was just uploaded like
two days ago on YouTube so right now I'm
going to analyze it I'm gonna check it
out and analyze it with you guys here
now remember the quality is pretty poor
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pause
in certain places and it enhanced the
image so that I can show you what I'm
talking about but yeah let's just get
into it let's analyze this baby
it starts off right away with someone
live-action zero someone dressed in a
live actually zero costume talking in
his epic zero way and I think that's the
original voice actor and then we see
clips a bunch of clips from the original
series from my first season in r2 who I
believe now let's listen to him a little
bit real live zero classic zero hand
gestures okay well let's see the clips
the clips that they show us in this this
I believe was the anniversary
celebration 10-year anniversary
celebration cokie us where this happened
we're hearing the epic music it's old
dark the expectation and i'm there's two
japanese symbols I'm gonna say it's Code
Geass but I really need to learn
Japanese we see zeroes mask damaged
on the beach so of course our ministry
what happened to zero makes this thing
we're seeing an explosion you can see
right here oh and here we can see lady
Kaguya so I'll just pause right here you
can see she looks a bit older and
apparently from what we know now there's
gotta be three or four years between art
to the ending of art - and when this
show is happening when the sequel starts
so we can expect all our characters to
be a bit older including Donal including
Lelouch Colin and everybody else clan of
course the studio oh here we see Colin
okie and Tamaki but appears to be making
a bunch of food so working at a
restaurant
I guess so this is like a peaceful time
still we're at a peaceful time right now
and then some stuff is gonna happen here
we see someone in the zero costume
moving with a lot of agility right and
we know that our buddy Lelouch is not
very agile so this is either Suzaku is
agile or someone else posing a zero
maybe a third party we don't know and
here we see what looks like an ancient
temple somebody's going towards an
ancient temple light this I think is a
big deal because if you watch my video
where I talked about speculated what I
think is going to happen in season three
I think that the ancient civilization of
beings with code that first built the
thought elevators that Charles uses to
activate the Ragnarok connection I think
they are going to make an appearance in
the sequel it is established in season
one and two that there was once an a
powerful ancient civilization that
created these thought elevators but we
don't know much about them we don't know
what happens to them we don't know where
they went
so I think in the sequel we're going to
learn more about them about the origins
of code and Geass look at the frame here
real quick that these people from the
original series you see this frame flash
a bit first time you luge gets his Geass
from say - you see this flash I think
that these people are the code the
ancient beings would call it the ancient
civilization similar to the myth of
Atlantis in our own world we don't know
much about them but they were clearly
powerful they were advanced so we might
learn more about them in the sequel at
least I hope so
we see a landslide year at the shinkiro
again
here we see orange being attacked
apparently Jeremiah Gottwald this just
looks like an airport don't know what
you're showing is dead then some
nightmares and the forest explosions in
an urban area so clearly some sort of
threat they're trying to tell us
something something is coming oh and
here again that you see that it looks
like an ancient temple like a big Buddha
statue on ancient temple and Cornelia is
going there for some reason so again
it's emphasizing to me the ancient
civilization aspect the ancient the
users of code and Geass the origins of
coding Geass are going to be a big part
of the sequel another explosion
lots of explosion of this one here we
see Suzaku running for his life
apparently outside of the zero costume
[Music]
ominous music of course epic build-up
and this is uh zeroes AI or Lelouch is I
of course I'll put a image up here with
Lelouch and so you can tell that it says
I because and I say this because there's
been a debates about rumors about a new
Geass user being the threat in the new
villain but this definitely looks like
Lelouch here so I don't think in this
trailer they introduced a new Geass user
will see and that said we have applause
we have epicness but check this out so
again I don't speak Japanese if someone
does please translate this part for me
especially because we see 2017 of course
the sequel is coming up but look at that
three now that three tells me either
it's talking about the three films that
are coming out the three recap films to
the original series or it might be
saying season three so I'd love to know
what that actually says if you speak
Japanese let me know because obviously
if it's a season three that's a big deal
so yeah this is really cool and
interesting but we don't learn that much
from this trailer we don't learn too
much about the new stuff that's going to
be happening in the sequel I am
definitely curious though about those
temples so we saw two separate shots of
what looked like ancient temples so
that's the highlight for me I want to
see what's going on there what's
happening there so yeah guys let me know
if you like these quick analysis type of
videos let me know if you want to see
more of these there's also a new attack
on Titan season 2 trailer 2 just came
out today so if you want to see me
analyze that let me know if you want to
see more attack on Titan stuff of you
guys mentioned in the chat if you want
to see some theories of what attack on
Titan let me know thanks again for all
the support and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]